[Music]
it was the perfect wedding the guests
thought the groom was Orpheus the
greatest of all poets and musicians the
bride Eurydice a wood nymph anyone could
tell the couple was truly and deeply in
love suddenly Eurydice stumbled then
fell to the ground by the time
Orpheus reached her side she was dead
and the snake that had bitten her was
slithering away through the grass
following Eurydice --zz funeral Orpheus
was overcome with a grief the human
world could not contain and so he
decided he would journey to the land of
the Dead a place from which no living
creature had ever returned to rescue his
beloved when Orpheus reached the gates
of the underworld he began to strum his
lyre the music was so beautiful that
Cerberus the three-headed dog who guards
the dead lay down as Orpheus passed her
on the ferry captain who charged Dead
Souls to cross the river Styx was so
moved by the music that he brought
Orpheus across free of charge when
Orpheus entered the palace of Hades and
Persephone the king and queen of the
Dead he began to sing he sang of his
love for Eurydice and said she had been
taken away too soon the day would come
when she liked all living creatures
dwelled in the land of the dead for all
eternity so couldn't Hades grant her
just a few more years on earth in the
moment after Orpheus finished all hell
Stood Still
Sisyphus no longer rolled his rock up
the hill Tantalus did not reach for the
water he would never be allowed to drink
even the Furies the demonic goddesses of
vengeance wept Hades and Persephone
granted Orpheus's plea but on one
condition as he climbed back out of the
underworld he must not turn around to
see if your itta sea was following
behind him if he did she would return to
the land of the dead forever
Orpheus began to climb with each step he
worried more and more about whether
Eurydice was behind him he heard nothing
where were her footsteps finally just
before he stepped out of the underworld
and into the bright light of day he gave
in to temptation
Orpheus tried to return to the
underworld but was refused entry
separated from Eurydice Orpheus swore
never to love another woman again
instead he sat in a grove of trees and
sang songs of lovers there was Ganymede
the beautiful boy who Zeus made drink
bearer to the gods
there was Mira who loved her father and
was punished for it and Pygmalion who
sculpted his ideal woman out of ivory
then prayed to Venus until she came to
life
and there was Venus herself whose
beautiful Adonis was killed by a wild
boar It was as if Orpheus's own love and
loss had allowed him to see into the
hearts of gods and people everywhere for
some however poetry was not enough a
group of wild women called the mean ads
could not bear the thought that a poet
who sang so beautifully of love would
not love them their jealousy drove them
to a frenzy and they destroyed poor
Orpheus the birds nature's singers
mourned Orpheus as did the rivers who
made music as they babbled the world had
lost two great Souls Orpheus and
Eurydice had loved each other so deeply
that when they were separated Orpheus
had understood the pain and joys of
lovers everywhere and a new art form the
love poem was born while the world wept
Orpheus found peace and his other half
in the underworld there to this day he
walks with Eurydice along the banks of
the river Styx sometimes they stroll
side by side sometimes she is in front
and sometimes he takes the lead turning
to look back at her as often as he likes
ted-ed is a non-profit if you value our
work please consider supporting it on
patreon.com slash ted-ed
[Music]